MAGGIE JOHNSON:
The way that Google
started was an academic venture.
JEFF DEAN: How do you
find interesting problems
in the world?
ALFRED SPECTOR: Google
depends on academia.
So many of the good ideas
that we have brought forward
to the world come from academia.
JEFF DEAN: One of the real
reasons to engage with academia
is to get a really
fresh perspective.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We
empower academics
to work on real problems.
And in the other
direction, academics
bring ideas and
new approaches that
are put into practice
much more quickly
than in an academic environment.
JEFF DEAN: Oh,
that's interesting.
That's interesting.
All of a sudden,
you've knitted together
something that's really,
really tremendously powerful.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We need their
help because of the problem
we're trying to
solve internally.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Academia can
look far out into the future.
It can take greater risks and
look for really interesting
solutions that industry
sometimes cannot.
DAVID KONERDING: Hi,
I'm David Konerding.
I'm a software
engineer at Google,
and I work on scientific
computing problems.
KAI KOHLHOFF: Hi,
I'm Kai Kohlhoff.
I'm a research scientist
here at Google.
And I used to work on protein
structure and protein dynamics
before coming here.
When I was applying to
Google, I was actually
thinking of just spending
three to six months
and just trying out some
bioinformatics algorithms
on some of Google technologies.
And when I actually heard
about what Dave was doing,
I was really
surprised because it
meant I could just
continue my work
but doing it at an
even larger scale.
DAVID KONERDING:
Yeah, Exacycle was
inspired by Folding@home and
Seti@home and other volunteer
computing projects.
But we had an even
more ambitious goal.
What we realized
was when you had
that much computing
available to you,
the amount of data you generated
overwhelmed every computing
system's power to analyze it.
I was originally the software
developer for Exacycle and Kai
focused primarily on running
his simulations on the platform.
Eventually we kind
of converged and Kai
was spending as much time
developing the software.
He helped us launch
it to trusted testers
and did a tremendous
amount of work
on the software
engineering side.
And it was really valuable
because that gave me
the feedback from a real user
who could also understand how
the system worked on the inside.
And we used his insights
to improve the system such
that when we started delivering
it to more scientists,
they said, OK.
This already has the
features we want.
Speaking of the scale that Kai
said, importantly, not only did
it have been roughly
the number of computers
available that Folding@home
would have provided him,
he had it dedicated to himself.
So for a short
period of time, Kai
had access to more
computing power
than any other
person on the planet.
We basically ran
up to 700,000 cores
simultaneously, days
upon days upon days
upon months up to
several years in fact,
running these simulations.
What this allows
scientists to do
is carry out science and
ask questions more quickly
and get feedback
faster than they
would be able to, while also
spending much less money.
What we'd like to do is actually
take the kinds of things
that we learn and share
them with the world.
I think that it's really
going to benefit scientists
and industry and the
government if they
know how to deal with
systems of this scale.
We're actually publishing
papers with methods
that explain how
we did what we did,
how to reproduce what we did,
and how to analyze the data,
and then making that data
available to everyone
so that they can process it.
I don't think that
this has really
been seen before in
academia, where people
are sharing hundreds of
terabytes with other people
and saying there's probably a
lot of useful data out there.
Here's how we explored it.
Why don't you also use
similar techniques, like Flume
to analyze that data at scale.
And so we think that this is
going to completely transform
how people do molecular dynamics
and a lot of different kinds
of data and compute
driven sciences.
KAI KOHLHOFF: I really have
the best of both worlds
here, because at
Stanford I had the chance
to take on the risk of studying
a G protein-coupled receptor
without knowing what
the outcome might be.
And I basically spent over
a year just looking at it
and trying to figure out
how I can best simulate it,
and how to build a system that
will be stable at large scale.
And so being able to take
on that risk in academia
is one thing, but then
you come to a company,
and suddenly everything
is really efficient.
And you get high
throughput very quickly.
And you kind of combine
these two things,
and that's how you
really can make progress.
DAVID KONERDING: What I'm
trying to do right now
is take the experiences that Kai
and the other visiting faculty
have and figure out ways that
we can make Exacycle easier,
so users don't
have to understand
how to scale systems
to that level.
They should just be able to
describe the problem that they
have and point us at the
tools, and we handle things
like scaling the IO
and running millions
of jobs at the same time.
These are hard problems.
And Google has a lot
of experience doing it
for its own business.
And we think we can
translate that and expose
that kind of functionality
through our cloud
to a really wide range of users.
KAI KOHLHOFF: I
think that's actually
kind of the vision
for the future,
because as a researcher,
you should really
be able to focus
on your research.
You shouldn't
spend all your time
just administrating servers and
building out the infrastructure
and programming and trying
to get everything to work.
What it should be
like is that you
know exactly what
you want to simulate.
And you should just basically
send that off somewhere
without knowing exactly
what's happening,
just knowing that your
data comes back eventually
and then knowing how
to deal with that.
And so your job
would be much more
just devising
experiments, carrying out
the simulations, and then
the analyzing the results
and writing the papers,
rather than also
having to deal with all the
technical issues in between.
It was just really fascinating
to see in which scale
you can actually think.
And everything becomes
basically just data driven.
You don't really think about
the smaller things anymore.
You just say, OK,
we're just going
to throw data at the
problem, and everything
will come together.
Because it actually I think
also changed my thinking.
Because initially,
I thought, OK,
if you want to
study a protein, you
have to come up with
some hypotheses.
And then we need to find
a way to prove these.
But I think what it became in
the end is that you suddenly
just generate lots
and lots of data.
And then all of these things
that you wanted to investigate,
they basically kind
of pop out of the data
by just doing the right thing.
So it's not really
biased in that way.
And I think that's very
typical for Google.
You just basically let
the data speak for itself
rather than trying
to interpret it
before you actually
go and look at it.
DAVID KONERDING:
I think it's going
to make a tremendous
change in the future.
I'm already starting to
see the next generation
of grad students moving onto
the cloud, Amazon and Google,
using GitHub, being
very sophisticated
about their software
development processes,
and also their data management
and network communication
processes.
So we're starting
to see the beginning
of an exponential increase
in scientific progress
as a function of the
ability to analyze
enormous amounts of data.
KAI KOHLHOFF: And I think
that's just one part of it.
I think you also start creating
this kind of dialogue where
your data is online.
Your processing has being done
online, somewhere in the cloud.
So really your experiments have
become much more reproducible.
You just tell people,
here are my scripts.
Here's the data.
You can run all of
this in the cloud,
and you can change the
parameters at will.
DAVID KONERDING:
What we want to do
is see more and more of that
data live in Google's cloud
and in Amazon's cloud
and in Microsoft's cloud
and be accessible to hundreds
or thousands of scientists.
Get away from the file formats.
Get used to dealing
with hundreds
of terabytes stored
in the cloud.
And don't be afraid of that.
There are ways to manage
that kind of data.
And we've publish papers
explaining how to do it.
And the open source
community has now
made those things
available to everybody.
I hope you'll go and watch the
Tech Talk that Kai and I put
together to speak about what
he did with Exacycle at Google.
KAI KOHLHOFF: And here are some
of the highlights of our talk.